danke danke leute für 500.000 abonnenten
die letzten tage waren so krank für mich
dass sie überhaupt keine chance hatte
mich irgendwie darauf vorzubereiten ich
will euch das gerne mal zeigen dass hier
ist mein kanal und die abonnentenzahlen
dreiundzwanzigster elfter 268 28 der
elfter 171 29 der f24 war u4 vierter
zwölfter 2074 ab diesem moment ist auf
youtube geführt der himmel über mich
eingebrochen ist unglaublich 7800 hier
dann haben wir hier 13.000 8000 6.000
8.000 ich hoffe ihr versteht warum ich
nicht wirklich hierauf vorbereitet bin
ich befinde mich gerade mitten im stress
weil ich morgen in den urlaub fahre und
habe 500.000 abonnenten erreicht ich bin
jetzt seit 2013 auf youtube ich habe
damit ihr versteht wie schnell das ging
zirka ein fünftel meiner abonnenten in
den letzten drei wochen gemacht aus
diesem grund möchte ich einfach danke
sagen sowohl den leuten die schon seit
anfang an dabei sind als vielleicht dir
wenn du jetzt gerade erst abonniert hast
ich weiß ihr youtuber sagt danke und ich
kann nicht mehr tun heißt das für meinen
teil auch zu machen
ihr kennt wahrscheinlich die worte die
jeder anschlägt ich habe durch euch so
viele möglichkeiten bekommen ich habe
freunde gewonnen und all das möchte ich
auch sagen aber wirklich von herzen wie
ich gesagt habe konnte ich jetzt leider
wie ich gesagt habe bin ich gerade
mitten im stress und konto leider
wirklich keine special vorbereiten
glaubt aber nicht dass es keines geben
wird ist wird noch eins kommen
ich wollte es kann einfach mal die
auszeit vom schneiden und vorbereiten
für den urlaub nehmen um genau dich
wissen zu lassen dass ich sehr schätze
dass du mich unterstützt mir folgt und
dir meine videos rein siehst ist immer
schwierig worte anzuschlagen die andere
leute noch nicht gewählt haben in so
einem dankes video und ich finde es auch
wichtig das zu tun weil ich bin euch
verbunden
es fühlt sich an als wäre das irgendwie
auf eine engere weise als das was man so
oft auf youtube gehört hat aus diesem
grund danke mehr kann ich nicht sagen
das video ist kurz ich hätte sonst
keines machen können und ich wollte aber
nicht an diesem für mich sehr großen tag
ein video machen
passau heuer auf wir sehen uns morgen
wieder und bis dahin macht's gut